education is a human right for sure and
internet access is such a fundamental
part of learning that by extension it is
almost certainly a human right within a
very short period of time it will be
particularly because of those who don't
have schools those who have to do their
learning on their own and for them
internet access is access to other
people it's not so much the knowledge
it's not the Wikipedia but it's the
connection to others particularly kids
to other kids peer-to-peer learning so
yes internet access will be a human
right at the moment it's it's edging up
to it and probably not everybody agrees
but they will shortly because i believe
the internet is a human right we can
look at the number of people on the
internet at the moment which is anywhere
between two or three billion people
depending how you count out of seven and
the next billion is a little bit like
low-hanging fruit you can do some
regulatory changes you can do some
subsidies you can you can bring the next
billion in quite easily to me I'm much
more interested in the last billion
because the last billion people are a
technology problem in many ways they're
a cultural problem they're in low
density areas mostly rural there they're
just many challenges which make the two
problems the next billion and the last
billion different problems and i'm
interested always in the harder problem
in the one that may be normal market
forces won't do and so i have been
involved in the past six eight months in
trying to bring the internet to those
last billion people and because they are
in low density rural areas I focused on
geostationary satellites not just
because
they have a big footprint but because
they're there and fifty percent of the
bandwidth over Africa for example is not
being used at the moment so there's a
lot of unused capacity you can move
satellites quite easily and then you can
launch a satellite so there's a pretty
orderly schedule for for how you would
do this and then the other thing which
people forget is that the liability in
the asset of geostationary satellites
are the same namely if you're going up
22,500 miles and back down again it's a
pretty long round trip the latency the
power all of those issues but Africa is
the same as Europe as far as the
satellites concerned so if the
satellites position somewhere in an
orbital slot over Africa on the equator
it sort of looks down to the right and
sees Africa looks down to the left sees
Europe so you can build a system that
serves Africa by landing in Europe
because one of the reasons you don't
want to land in Africa is that that the
sort of backbone of the internet in
Africa is quite costly and landing in
Europe is not very costly so you could
have what's called a you know a farm of
dishes in some location in Europe that
serves Africa not the long term solution
but a very quick short term solution and
I believe that one should be doing these
things now with resolve there's no
there's no technical hoback it's just a
couple of billion dollars to do it and
that's what we spend in Afghanistan and
one week so it's it's it's this isn't
off the charts
you